now have a listen to this a staff member
at one of canada's biggest hockey teams
has thanked a fan who saved his life
after spotting a mole on the back of his
neck nadia popovich wrote notes on her
phone and signaled to brian hamilton to
read it and after seeing a doctor brian
hamilton confirmed the mole was in fact
cancerous and was later removed i'm
delighted to say that nadia joins us now
good to see you on sky news thank you
for your time today so you are being
regarded as a hero a heroine by many
uh yes it's it's still so much to wrap
my head around thank you so much for
having me it's this is surreal
now take us back what were you doing
there in the first place are you a big
hockey fan
oh huge yes i've grown up actually a fan
of the opposing team the canucks uh the
kraken is a brand new team in washington
state and in the states and uh this was
their very first home game against the
canucks
my old favorite team
uh and so i had to be there i was so
lucky that my my stepdad was able to
invite me and bring me into that seat
now take us back this was october the
23rd i believe so just over a couple of
months ago
and you were sitting there what did you
notice uh as far as mr hamilton's
concerns
yeah so uh he was a stranger at the time
he was actually located across from me
for the entire game so he wasn't even in
front of me for most of the game
but he happened to walk in front a
couple of times and during one of those
times he reached for something and the
lapel of his jacket fell down a little
and i was standing right behind him at
the time and i noticed a a dark spot and
it was a mole
so i was curious and i leaned up close
to the glass to take a a better look and
i noticed that you know it was
discolored it had irregular borders uh
it was pretty large and it was raised
and i knew those um just coming from a
little bit of a medical background that
those were possible indicators of skin
cancer and that he should likely be
seeing a doctor
goodness so i suppose you felt fairly
helpless did you and then
something
inspirational kicked in what did you do
yes yeah i i mean you can't speak
through the glass it's very hectic in
the arena
and so i thought you know if that was my
family member up there i would want
someone to say something and the only
way that i can say something is through
text through my phone so i pulled out my
notes app and i just quickly typed in
the mole on the back of your neck is
possibly cancerous please go see a
doctor
and i put mole cancer and doctor in
bright red and bolded font to see you
know if he only has one second to glance
at it maybe something will register and
the moment came together it was a
somewhat of a private moment and he was
able to read it i put my phone up to the
glass and knocked really loud uh and he
he took a look and uh
it was in the back of his mind and i'm
just so happy it turned out in the best
possible way could you see what his
reaction was when he managed to see your
notes
yes yeah so he he saw it and then he
kind of shrugged and and walked away
and after that moment i i kind of
regretted it i thought you know oh that
was inappropriate i shouldn't have
brought it up and maybe he already knows
about it and it's a sensitive topic and
so i just to not know for so many months
what happened to this man
and to finally put a name to the face
and and a story i mean it's it's been
incredible and and truly life-changing
so i suppose you didn't really know what
happened he saw this then went off and
this was in october we do know that he
he went to the doctor and got this
removed
but you perhaps wouldn't know that would
you because you hadn't been in contact
for a while
right i knew absolutely nothing until
just two nights ago when the story
dropped on social media and twitter had
a manhunt for me and
i mean i remember waking up that day to
my mom's phone call and she's screaming
and she says
nadia you have no idea what's going on
right now
and i i opened the the kraken team's
twitter
and there's red's story and he is
explaining how he he got it diagnosed
and removed and he's now cancer free and
all of this was happening and i had no
idea and
i mean
it's just so amazing to see how the
internet pulled together and and how
many people have been inspired by the
story to you know not only in in a
healthcare way to check themselves but
you know inspired by the unity between
the kraken and the canucks uh teams
uh it's not just while you're there let
us look at the moment that you did meet
brian red hamilton just a couple of days
ago
hi
hello hi it's so nice to me are you okay
with shaking hands
[Music]
thank you
what was that like to actually uh get to
see him and realize he'd done so much
good
yeah oh my goodness i mean
being able to hear from his mouth this
the story of what it was like on the
other side of the glass you know the the
confusion and the fear and
going home to his partner and saying do
i even have a mole on the back of my
neck um he he didn't even know it was
there let alone you know cancerous and
just to know that i was i was the
catalyst for that um is absolutely i
mean
i still can't believe it and now i mean
i've been able to speak to his family
while while i met him over face time and
i mean we're connected uh on social
media and i i just feel like this has
brought me and and his families together
forever and i i mean i'll i'll never
forget him
of course and a happy new year for you
and him and uh what have people done to
help you and your uh progression through
medical school
yes yeah so uh at the the game that i
attended where i got to meet red they
announced on the you know big booming
mic to the whole arena that they came
together as two teams and were giving me
a ten thousand dollar scholarship
and i almost fell back i
can't believe it even to this day i mean
i sat in my seat afterwards they
announced it and i i cried for like 10
or 15 minutes because
i mean really that money is is
it means so much to me and the
generosity
how many people have gone out of their
way to to welcome me and to tell me
their stories i mean
this scholarship is going to be applied
directly back into my medical education
and i'm just hoping i can have so many
more interactions just like the one i
had with red um in a doctor's office
this time
brilliant well even more they're amazing
because you did this in october it all
went away and you thought you'd hear
nothing more about it
right exactly yes i thought it was over
and it was just going to be a story in
my head that was a little bit awkward
but
i mean truly one amazing story
nadia well done and uh thank you very
much indeed for telling us your story
great to see you
thank you